uh good morning everyone um I'm
representative Sellers and I'm going to
call the meeting to order and let's say
the Pledge of Allegiance and we'll go on
you okay we uh we came back in session
because we uh last time uh we just
didn't vote as far as a um you know what
the to do with the the bill so today
we're here to actually vote on it but
also I'm willing to take any other
testimony anybody else wants to share
anything else about um HB what is it HB
FN does anybody want to share anything
today we'll just give the uh the
teenagers a license and call it a day
kidding okay then um I'm I'm ready for a
motion and at this point if someone
wants to make a
motion um I'll make a motion to uh place
it in interm study or recommend it goes
an inter term
that okay any
discussion I just think it's clear that
it needs to be um yeah needs to be
studied I think there's a lot of moving
parts and I don't think we want to do
anything too quickly but I think it's
into no yeah I concur as well because I
I I I think parents are still able to do
this but
again I know from what what we heard
from uh the folks out there it's it's uh
dicey but there's a lot to it a lot of
moving Parts I guess so um to study a
little bit more I don't think would hurt
so um then we'll go ahead and take a
votee any other
discussion okay all in favor of the
interim study say I I I I opposed
study okay um I don't think there's any
other business or anybody else have
discuss okay hold
on Senator we just voted we to make this
an interim study I'm sorry we just voted
to make this an interim study okay just
to let you
know do you have anything else that
you'd want to speak on in this
bill
okay um at this point then I think we're
set to um actually close the meeting all
up